let's talk about one of the best
nutrients for improving
your thinking and that would be choline
now choline was once considered one of
the b
vitamins but now it's considered kind of
a standalone vitamin but
choline which by the way is a kind of a
lemon
tasting vitamin you can even suck on
them and they taste like a little lemon
drop
it's a required nutrient by your body
because it's a primary building block
of something called acetylcholine which
is a
neurotransmitter for your brain
neurotransmitters work like
hormones but instead of traveling
through the blood
they travel through the nervous system
so it's involved in
communication as improving new memories
it's involved in certain processes that
influence reasoning concentration
focus cognition which is
understanding things sleep
growing synapses in your brain cells
and coordinating movements especially
movements involving speed and accuracy
and there's some really interesting
research
on this i'm going to put it down below
of people taking choline
and noticing some significant
improvements
in these right here now if you're
deficient in choline
you have a tendency to get brain fog you
have problems with the tension and
focus you can even develop brain fatigue
decreased ability to learn things
memory loss poor recall get distracted
easily which is part of this right here
and becoming irritable
other than that you'll be pretty good
now the question is where would you get
choline
in your diet number one source beef
liver
just 2.4 ounces will give you 290
milligrams
shrimp is a good source of choline 4
ounces provide 153 milligrams
but just one egg will give you 146
milligrams i personally consume a lot of
eggs
and then we have scallops four ounces of
scallops will give you 125
milligrams now there's a lot of other
foods that will provide
choline including even leafy greens but
these
are probably the best sources right here
and so if you have some of these
symptoms right here
and you want to improve these and you're
starting to consume these foods
or even taking colon as a supplement
and it doesn't work there's something
else that is a requirement to make sure
this works
and that is making sure that your diet
is correct you're avoiding certain
things
that deplete choline and for that
information i put a link down below if
you're new to my channel
to know exactly how to do that thanks
for watching
before you go if you have a question
about a product or you're new to keto
and you want to know how to begin
keto or you're on keto and you need a
debug because it's not going as smooth
i have a keto consultant standing by to
help you
this is just for the people in the us
hopefully in the future we'll be able to
answer everyone's call
but i put the number down below so you
can call
and get some help